nocturne was great
just want to say congrats on the movie
and people should definitely tune in
when it's on amazon
uh and we're going to get to that
project but i got a bunch of things i
want to talk to you about
so uh let's get started um
were you more nervous meeting quentin
tarantino for the first time
or taking a picture with one direction
oh my god
um how can you even ask that question
16 year old me was beyond nervous
taking a picture of one direction uh
i was 20 20 year old me
was beyond nervous making wanting to
make sure i impressed quentin tarantino
so i think it was like
different aged nervousness but both
equally in their own way
crazy i have to ask you most people
don't get to go backstage at a concert
how did you manage to get backstage to
meet one direction
my best friend in high school had the
ultimate
dad hookup for live nation concert
tickets
the connection is always how it works um
uh
obviously like everyone i am a huge
quentin fan
um i am curious if you don't mind
sharing what was it like to be on set
with him watching him direct
the best acting school workshop you
could ever
ask for i mean he's just he's such a
brilliant mind
and the way he just brings the whole
movie to life on a set in
a completely different way is
unbelievable and the way he works with
everyone and
he's so immersed in the characters and
the writing of course and like it truly
generally makes him
happy so being able to see someone who
who loves their work is
a lot of fun obviously you you're a
clinton fan just like all of us
and so i am curious what did you pay him
to be in the movie
um you know i actually so
during the audition process there was a
thing on the audition notice saying that
you could
do extra credit like you could bring in
a monologue you could
uh prepare a song like anything
creatively you wanted to do
so i ended up writing a letter as
another mansion girl
as if i was writing a letter to charlie
and i read the letter
in the audition room and then he asked
to keep the letter so that was kind of
cool
that was that was my payment i wrote a
letter to charlie
uh that's awesome yeah cool because like
other girls were like
painting pictures and writing songs and
it was like
something i've never done or been asked
to do before
in an audition and uh he he really
appreciated the people who
who did that uh yeah i'm thinking
yeah that's that's awesome um i read and
i don't know if this is true
that uh when you were younger you really
wanted to be an actor
and you presented your parents with a
five-year plan like a business plan
um is that true it is true
um my both my parents were very strict
like still are uh
school and education is always number
one in their lives
and they're both very smart individuals
and
so the whole creative artsy world was a
different planet to them and
the only way to communicate my dreams
was to be able to do it on a level that
they would understand
and so i i put a business band together
i was like all right smart people
this is what i want to do um first of
all
that's amazing and second of all it
totally worked
it took it took a little longer than my
business plan said but you know we're
here
completely um you've been working i
believe since 2009
and you're now in your early 20s i would
imagine when you first started working
stepping on a tv set or a movie set must
have been like oh my effing god this is
amazing
how has that changed it all for you as
you've now
now that it's become almost like this is
your job is you know working on movies
working on tv
has has do you still have that same
energy and excitement when you step on
set or
has it settled a little bit i still get
this nervous excitement on every single
set because
every character and all the people are
always different so
i get really excited to be able to try
new things and meet new people but
as i've gotten older i also do look at
it as more of
a job and a business but i still have
like that nervous excitement
i've been asking this question of
everyone i've been talking to the last
few months for the next two questions
uh what tv series would you love to
guest star on
ah yellowstone okay
that was not what i was expecting at all
um have you seen have you seen all three
seasons
yes i benched them during quarantine
really
uh and i think it has to do with taylor
sheridan uh because you know he's a
great writer also
amazing but like i i would like to move
there
also and live on a ranch so
got it um what movie have you seen the
most
this is such a hard one because like
different times a year i'll watch
different things like
harry potter i always watch over and
over again
from thanksgiving to christmas but then
also titanic i have on like a daily
repeat so i don't know which one i
have seen more i'll we can move on um
jumping into why i actually get to talk
to you today okay
i know you're like will we ever get
there the answer is no it's okay i love
the fun questions
um what was it about this project though
that said
what was it about the script and the
story that said i want to be a part of
this
so i was coming off of cassie and
euphoria and i was just looking for
something that was a complete polar
opposite
to my character and when i read nocturne
it reminded me
of black swan in a sense and i was a
huge fan of that and i think natalie
portman's incredible
and i was i was like i could do
something here i can challenge myself
and i just dove in and i really enjoyed
it
when you're meeting with zoo to discuss
the role are you like
yeah i cannot really play piano that
well so we're gonna cheat that right
um actually i might have said i've had
some piano experience
just to make sure that i was like i
could do this
and then i was telling myself that i'll
just take as many piano lessons as fast
as i could
uh they they had a pianist
teach us the different songs not like
fully because when i actually sat down
to look at the music i was like oh my
god this is going to take me years
but they had someone work on the
choreography of
the song so like where our bodies would
be our shoulders our hands and like
where
on the piano we would be at that time
and i ended up actually
buying an electric piano to practice on
and i've enjoyed it and i've taught
myself a little bit here and there but
yeah well what's interesting is i just
spoke to
anya taylor joy about queen's gambit and
one of the things about that movie is or
that series is that
the chess moves are essentially her
action sequences
and in this project you playing the
piano again
is like your action sequence is playing
the piano
and learning as you said um uh talk
about the challenge of like
trying to memorize these moves you know
and get it right
it was very challenging because zeus
actually from a
musical theater background and she i
believe that she was like a part of the
orchestra growing up
and so she was very passionate about
making sure to portray this school and
the instruments and the players
correctly
and so if i was like a beat behind and i
was too far up
i'd be like i gotta start over and it
was just it was a lot of work to make
sure that we
we showed it as real as possible before
you obviously stepped on set you're
looking at the script you're looking at
everything you have to do besides the
piano stuff
i'm curious what were you maybe nervous
to be able to pull off with the schedule
and the
budget you guys had to work with uh it
was definitely a very very
quick short prod schedule we had 20 days
to film the entire movie which
it takes us more than 20 days to film an
episode of euphoria
so going from that to having just
little time was stressful but also
you come up with a lot of creative uh
maneuvers to get things done
and uh everyone was really just good
sports just
in it to get it done and make the film
as best as they could and
it was it was a challenge completely i
think for a lot of people they don't
realize
uh 20 days is not a lot of time to do
no because i mean like if you compare it
to euphoria we
we filmed for like nine months and
it's that's a long time then you have a
whole movie for 20 days that's like
filming
20 scenes it doesn't work well you
actually bring up something
i was going to get to euphoria later but
i'll ask it now
something about euphoria is you have
some very complicated camera moves
um and i'm curious what is it like on
set
uh setting working with this kind of
camera work
uh it's a lot of time it's a lot of
patience
and rehearsals and just making sure that
everything lines up perfectly and
and everyone's so great on that stuff
because they knew that if we
really put the effort and the hard work
and the time in that we could create
something
beautiful like euphoria and so everyone
was just
there to be able to make it and and we
just
we sat and we made sure that we got the
shots uh
but i mean like it would take us
sometimes a day to do two scenes because
there's just it was so much work
how do you as an actor stay emotionally
present
in a moment like that which is going on
for a very long time
so and also like hitting your marks when
the camera is doing some of this stuff
how
how challenging is that um you know the
the whole
the staying in the emotional part it's
for me i'm able to like jump in and out
of it that part
isn't the crazy hard part uh
hitting the marks at the exact right
time when the camera is in that position
and the lighting and
that sometimes i'm like oh my god
but they're jumping in and out um i've
as i've gotten older i've gotten
better at being able to shut off shut on
when i need to nocturne is streaming on
amazon and um
i'm curious for you because you're
younger than i am
i i revere going to the movies like the
movie
going to a movie theater is like my
church my temple it's
it's everything but i also love watching
movies at home
how is it for you being like a younger
generation do you still have that
my god i want to see everything in a
movie theater or are you very
comfortable
with watching everything at home i love
going to movie theaters
i had my first date in a movie theater i
love eating candy and popcorn and i
usually
like to dress all comfy and go to
theaters uh i miss it
uh i think that i do enjoy watching
movies at home
i enjoy watching tv at home in movies in
a movie theater but
i'd like to go back i am counting
counting the days um with euphoria do
you know
when uh you might be filming again what
or
are you involved like how does that when
it's safe for
all of us to go back and be able to film
euphoria to euphoria's
greatest standards got it i understand
um you uh recently announced a new
series uh with
i want to pronounce how housing
halsey yeah i'm really bad with names
and everyone's going to be okay
right now um but can for people that um
had
heard about the project what can you
actually say about it and when are you
planning
what's going on with it yeah so i
started
a production company called 5050 films
and about a year ago i found the book it
used to be called the players table now
it's called they wish they were us it
was
it was released about a month ago and
when i read it
i was like this is the first project
that i would love to be able to
produce with my company and so i met
with the author jessica goodman
and she thankfully trusted me with her
baby
and i took it out and shopped it around
for a little bit
mark ballet nathan ross's crazy rose
were
amazing and we partnered together
to produce this and i called up
halsey and i was like do you want to
read this book i think there's an
amazing role for you in it
and i think that she could do wonders
with the role
and she fell in love with it and we've
been putting it together and we
uh we have an incredible filmmaker
annabella nacia who
is going to write and direct for us and
as soon as we get
everything put together we will film it
uh do you envision it as a
is this a limited series is this
something that could go for a little
while
uh we envision it as a limited series
but who knows
what could happen in the future got it
do you know how many episodes you're
trying to pull off
um don't know exactly like eight to ten
i understand um obviously uh
with you being a producer like you
congrats on being able to
make your own material that's awesome um
can you sort of talk about how does
stuff how would this stuff end up on
your lap at this point
in terms of because i'm sure if you now
that you can you know make stuff
i'm sure people are sort of reaching out
of the woodwork or whatever but
how what is it like for you trying to
figure out what material you want to
look at
you know what i mean it's actually
really challenging because i'm still the
point where
i want to do everything i kind of want
to try and dip my toes in
every genre every every partnership that
i can
and and it's so hard because you're like
what
will benefit my company or what wouldn't
and so just
trying to read as much as possible i
have people sending me pitches
scripts books i love books i'm a huge
reader
so i'm trying to find more books to
adapt myself so it's just taking the
time and
making sure that i choose things that
are meaningful
are impactful and and really either
speak to even a smaller audience and and
fun to make you have an awful large
following
on instagram and i'm curious how much
time do you spend
before you hit the button post
unfortunately a lot
um unfortunately i i i'm not gonna lie
like i'm not
i i'm not one of those people who's like
i'm super confident and
uh i i don't care what people think like
i'm not i'm a real person i care
whatever like what people think and what
they say and what they comment
um so i i definitely i'm always like oh
my god should i post this should i not
post this and it goes back and forth and
i post it i'm like oh my god should i
delete it like it's a whole thing
well no i mean i saw i think the best uh
bit that i saw was taylor swift when she
decided to enter the political arena and
she was and there was that moment where
they have it on camera
where she is with her mom or her team
and she's
literally debating hitting posts knowing
how that could
change everything for her and i you know
the power of social media
and i think that you know you have to
think about what you're actually
putting out there you do and there's
just there's such a big cancer culture
right now that's
i always feel like people can pick apart
anything and i'm terrified of like
what am i not aware of or thinking when
i post this like
and i don't want to be deaf to anything
going on so i was
i get really nervous uh speaking of
nervousness
um talk a little bit about if you don't
mind when was the last time
you were like really nervous on a set
you know for some reason or is that
something that you actually always deal
with
i always deal with that i'm always
nervous on
every set for a different reason um
either it's oh my god am i gonna
remember all my lines or
uh i'm really nervous around you know
dicaprio and brad pitt like
there's so many different types of nerve
and nervousness that
i have i deal with on a daily basis a
lot of actors i've spoken to
they talk about how their first take um
is where they have a lot of energy the
first two or three takes and other
people talk about how
it's like their eighth take or like
they're warming up to something
um for you do you feel like you're an
early take person
how how do you sort of typically like to
you know what i mean what's your energy
uh you know i haven't really truly paid
attention or thought
about that uh i think it just depends on
what director actors i'm working with
because sometimes directors
just do two takes and that's it and
that's all you got and then sometimes
directors do like 20 takes and you have
to give it
the same every single time so
i haven't really i hope that i give it
my all every single time now i'm like oh
my god did i did i
lose my energy halfway through that day
i mean but i've spoken to a lot of
people that talk about how
um and i've talked to a lot of it's
interesting talking to directors because
they'll tell me
that there are certain actors that the
first few takes they
know they're going to deliver and that
other actors they need to warm up a
little
bit and so it's just interesting hearing
the director perspective
and i'm always then curious about the
actor perspective and if it's in their
head at all that they know
that you know certain takes are better
than others i'm i'm definitely now going
to pay more attention to
myself
okay um with when you're on set and
you're filming
uh a lot of actors talk about um how
they're always thinking about down the
road that they might want to direct
or they want to know so much more about
the technical aspects of making a
project
so when you're sitting there working on
something like nocturne or euphoria
are you looking at where the camera is
what lenses they're using
are you like studying that for something
maybe down the road or are you sort of
just like i need to be present in what
i'm doing at this
exact moment i try to take away as much
as i can from every production i've
definitely noticed in the past like few
years i'm
really drawn to cinematography and
whether i dp one day
or if it's just me being able to direct
and have more of an insight
um for shot lists and and lighting and
lenses that i want
uh but i definitely i'm a very visual
person so
i'm i'm hoping that i can i can dive
into something like that
do you know what's coming up next for
you or are you sort of like
a little bit on pause mode because i
know with euphoria
like they sort of have you and when they
decide to film
like that's when you guys are gonna film
so how does that work in terms of trying
to
figure out what else you can do while
also waiting for that phone call
i actually have a few things uh i leave
next week to go film something that i
can't say yet but
um i i have a few things i've been
finessing in before i go back to
euphoria got it
um you are uh so you're leaving next
week
i am are you getting on an airplane i
might be going somewhere
i i got it um based on
is it in europe australia vancouver
it's somewhere nice and warm
i won't pressure you there because i i
know a lot of stuff where it's filming
so no i figured i figured i was like i
can't give too much away
yeah i mean if you told me you're going
to australia that's going to tell me
there are certain things that are
filming there
uh if you you know if you tell me you're
going to toronto you know what i mean
there's
yup i'm just going to say and i mean it
seriously
super happy to talk to you uh i've
really been a fan of your work
thank you for giving me your time and i
hope to talk to you again
at some point in the not so distant
future when you're promoting whatever it
may be
thank you so much this is a lot of fun